[Musique]
ce serait trop demander un service ou
ans en mer pour changer on dirait des
traces de piqûres nous a signé les deux
autres corps à l'autre bout de la ville
et les deux ont les mêmes traces sur la
nique
les trois victimes sont mortes quasiment
la même heure mais aux quatre coins de
la ville comment tu expliques ça
[Musique]
vous êtes vous
west university
salut thomas ce qu'est ce que vous
racontez
c'est ici que ça se passe
je me trouve dans le centre ville de
philadelphie en ce jour du neuvième
anniversaire de ce qu'on appelle les
meurtres de market street dans le
quartier
j'écoute c'est à dire comment ça ça
recommence
il faut vous venu voir sa police de
philadelphie vous avez déjà vu cette
femme je suis contente d'être voir il se
fait déchiqueter par un métro elle
revient à 9 ans plus tard
[Musique]
retrouvez la priorité absolue de tous
les services de police il faut car et de
poursuivre
je fais ça pour une bonne raison nous on
avance tout mais elle elle le redoutait
tu n'as aucune idée de ce qui va se
produire
si tu me tues maintenant le monde tel
que tu le connais disparaîtra